While it's great that we can query
our database through the content provider,
it would be nice if we
could also use the content provider
to put data in.
We'll begin with the insert function.
Let's fill the insert function
with the same Uri matcher code
we had in the other
content provider functions
but with one change.
We're only going to match
the base Uris.
There's a good reason for this.
When we insert into our database,
we want it to notify
every content observer
that might have data modified
by our insert.
It turns out that cursors
register themselves as notify
for descendants which means
that notifying the root Uri,
we'll also notify
all descendants of that Uri.
If we were to notify
based on anything else
other than the root Uri,
then a cursor
listening on the root Uri
will not get notified
of a change that
would certainly impact it.
So we have to be very careful
when doing that.
For this reason it makes a lot of sense
to only allow insertions
at our root Uri into our database.
That way, it's very, very easy
to handle notifications.
It means that we
also don't have to build
a combination query for our insert,
containing a parameter
coming from the Uri,
with the rest of the parameters
coming from a function.
So for weather we just pass the parameters
into a database insert call.
We should throw an exception
if the insert fails.
The only trick here is to make sure
we return the correct value,
which is a Uri.
Fortunately we made a function
to build these Uri's
which contain the weather path
followed by an _id.
Let's go task this.
Once again, we go to TestProvider
and we modify our test.
Because, after all, it's supposed
to be testInsertReadProvider.
Here's our insert statement.
Obviously it's still talking
to the database.
We're going to want to make it
talk to the provider.
As always, that's pretty straightforward.
We always get our provider
by using our ContentResolver
so we can replace
this insert statement with the db.
with a ContentResolver instead.
And, of course, we don't use
a ContentResolver against a TABLE_NAME.
Instead we do it against
the WeatherEntry.CONTENT_URI.
But there's still something wrong.
Of course, we don't actually return
the weatherRowId, we return a Uri.
But we can still get a weatherRowId.
How do we do that?
Quite simply.
Using a helper function in ContentUris,
and we don't really need that insert.
After all, we know that
this ContentResolver function
isn't actually going to return
unless the value is true.
Now that we finished that,
let's run the test,
and make sure that we can actually
insert using our content provider.
And our test passed.
Well, you know what time it is.
Time for you to write
some of this as well.